josh is gonna man hi guys how are you oh
my god yeah I got some headphones to put
on here jump right in
you were so unsane is one of these
movies that they shot we had what's his
name why am i blinking on his name ring
JJ Miller zero
well you know Jerry Lawler Jim Baker
Jerry the manager at Chili's
Encino yeah yeah that's also my favorite
Chili's yeah oh my god Chili's rules I
try to tell you Florentine makes fun of
me because when I go to LA I end up I've
eaten like I go to LA like two or three
times a year I shouldn't have gone to a
Chili's the same Chili's in LA multiple
times but I've probably been to that one
like half a dozen times it's fantastic
if you like that one you should also
check out the one in Glendale because
the control a lot of people say if I
like that one I should try literally all
Chili's everywhere if you like that one
you hang yourself yeah I love it also
fair I love it um but can we talk about
getting cracker barrels to Manhattan
Cracker Barrel is another great
restaurant I don't I'll eat on them on a
road but it's like you don't want to be
in New York it wouldn't make you happy
no it's just a darkness SAT food I don't
need Excel I get [ __ ] that's not true
it's a roadside indulgence and it's very
affordable I would take a waffle house
over to Cracker Barrel really yeah girls
menu is it just goes on forever I don't
I don't need a big menu I I know what
I'm eating I'm not even Wapiti combings
on there
I don't do that in the morning do that
at night after a few drinks
I love Cracker Barrel cuz they're very
unapologetic about what they are last
time go to a Cracker Barrel I was with
my wife and she like questioned it was
your wedding but she had ordered like I
don't know whatever probably a side of
broccoli or something and they bring out
our food and she goes don't worry it
your broccoli will be out in just a
second we're just nuking it right now
that's like just like talking about
microwave food
yeah we're microwaving your broccoli and
it's also when they put bacon bacon in
your in your broccoli and you're like I
well I'm a vegetarian like yeah yeah and
you don't even have to specifically ask
for bacon it's just a given like of
course if you get broccoli there's gonna
be bacon and like broccoli do you eat
man yeah so yeah no I don't [ __ ] with
those less I have to okay fair enough
you look skinny thank you yeah I feel
like if fatter than normal a little body
image issues whether your body
dysmorphia Pilates no what do you what
do you do at the gym what do you listen
to nothing with a trainer I don't have
any I know music on unless I'm alone
then I'll throw my dumb iPod but no I
always a really funny response what what
do you listen to the drink what about
when you work out on the road then I'll
put on music just you know what do you
listen to this Sabbath or uh Sean Paul I
mix it up between the oratorio most yeah
is a big John Paul I am I love Sean Paul
but I also love Sabbath like he's
literally he's on and it's not just like
for a thing like he's been on airplanes
that I've been on him with and like you
look at his phone and just Sean what
does that one he's like a Pilates Sean
Paul and then when you lift away a new
Sabbath
no so no I don't break it down like that
what's wrong you know because I would I
don't break it down into what I think
fits I just you know put on I gotta
promote a movie right so what I was
gonna say was Sean
Aker did he was I guess one of the first
guys to tangerine yet to make a movie
all on iPhones yeah you guys have done I
didn't realize I've seen the trailers
and stuff for unsane I didn't realize it
was all on iPhone until I was reading
about you like yesterday mm-hmm how is
that as an actor like to know does it
make you feel like are we doing a movie
here you know if not for the fact that
Steven Soderbergh's riding behind like
if Steven Soderbergh was my dad and we
were like hey let's make some family
movies except here are the lines for our
family movie that we're gonna make and
you're gonna also be really evil right
so that that was the experience but but
yeah it's such a III I mean look I've
got a 16 month old kid said the iPhone
is always coming out we did we're always
using its the omnipresent piece of
technology and it really it does feel
sometimes like are we just are we just
playing around here what are we doing
right it reduces you know it doesn't
feel like film with a capital F where
where any anybody takes themselves too
seriously
is there enough room on an iPhone
Hollywood just keep dumping it I mean I
have to keep talking I'll say I believe
he and I would be great if they didn't
dump it and they just had one phone and
it was the whole movie and on the last
day of shooting the thing just crashed
how are they how are they backing it up
like are they backing up as they shoot
it or they're back in there they're
backing it up as they shoot I believe he
had three iPhones it was the iPhone 7
when we shot what kind of lenses lenses
but you sometimes sometimes Annette now
when I went in I assumed it's like a
ring for it or something from because I
talked to Sean about making tangerine
and they had a whole setup to achieve
the aesthetic they had on this film so I
assumed we were gonna have all the bells
and whistles and but the iPhone was more
just you know this would be fun let's
let's it's Steven Soderbergh's new
experiment
he really loves the fact that it's that
small that is he loves being able to
move fast he loves the fact that you
don't have to light a lot and he loves
the fact that you can put a phone
anywhere you can put it all the way up
in the corner and and walk away you can
change that change the lensing in five
minutes so I would say 75% of the time
it was just him holding the iPhone with
no attachment filming us but color was
the phone Wow it was a black because I
feel I'm a Space Gray I have the red one
and I feel like that would make it I
don't weigh more distracting buddy with
the red one you also have a blue keys on
your phone so who the [ __ ] even know why
his pink one broke I don't think I never
had a pink phone you got a red phone you
have to have a pink case no it's I got
red phone dog dick sometimes he did have
he had a little Steadicam attachment
occasionally if he wanted to change the
lens sizing he'd he'd put an adapter on
but a lot of times we just shot on the
iPhone and and and the plan was to take
it to Netflix take it to a streaming
service but ultimately it was when he
was color correcting the movie and
looked at it on a big screen that he
realized that the image actually really
held up and and decided to do this big
theatrical release which excited the
hell out but I don't do them as well it
sounds stupid but if you put it in the
corner doesn't you don't you just get a
faraway image yeah it's so - like with
the prime lens you just move the camera
where you want the shot to be but it's
also I I guess it shoots 4k which is
super-high resolution so if you wanted
to you could probably also zoom in and
post-production about 20% yeah like chop
off the you names like stressed a little
bit yeah um and this is Jay Pharoah this
is first
he's formatic thing right I don't know
is it I don't know if he's done drew
stuff before money has yeah III think
he'd trained doing more dramatic stuff
and then and then in common and then
ended up in comedy he's great though
yeah he's really he's real natural it's
it's got to be nice to be the funny guy
in an otherwise scary in dense movie
because everybody just loves you like ah
that guy thank God that guy's on-screen
cuz whenever Josh Leonard comes
on-screen he's really mean at what point
did you realize because obviously we
were talking about before you came in
people first got familiar with you from
Blair Witch so at what point after Blair
Witch because that was such a phenomenon
did you realize okay I'm gonna be able
to keep working because people don't
even know you're actors when that moon
it's true we were we were listed on IMDB
is deceased is that real good quite
literally my folks got because of that
marketing campaign my folks got
condolence calls from people who hadn't
seen the family in a while because their
real names in the film and it was you
know three kids Josh Leonard Heather
Donahue and Mike Williams who went
missing in the woods and this is their
footage so your so your your your
parents friends thought that a you die
because of a ghost I mean when you watch
the movie it seems more real when you
break it down that bad yeah Wade they
were charismatic I saw that like a long
time after it came out it was already
like the hype around like I still like
that yeah we're still Friday I I always
thought the I mean I think the best way
to see that film was beef before you
know yeah before you knew yeah they were
there was kind of a time in a place
where I think it was really exciting but
when did you guys what did you guys this
I did break storyline on that and
actually admit that you were actors so I
remember in the promotion for it I think
like I was a kid and I was watching like
TRL or something on MTV and I don't know
if you were I feel like that makes me
feel when you're like I was when I was a
kid well my wife by the way cuz like my
parents wouldn't let me watch that and
I'm like go [ __ ] yourself
that's perfect are you married someone
who was too young to enjoy your film
that's good for you absolutely so so
have you met somebody that was like you
put on like your first couple specials
and they were like I wasn't even born
when my first one was 2007 I'm not that
[ __ ] I'm a girlfriend as I've seen this
last Network so but like when did you
guys decide to just break away from it
and just admit you're actors because I
remember watching I think that was the
show that I watched to be like what what
the [ __ ] I thought I think what was it
was probably about a week after the
movie came out that that that we started
doing a bunch of press on it they they'd
kept us hidden which which for us is
actors was was a bummer cuz we were you
know broken scrappy and right we're like
we have this movie that you know is
going to can no you guys can't go to can
we have this movie then you know needs
doing all these no you guys can't do it
just you know and I don't hold many
crutches in this world cuz it's not good
and it eats you up inside I will say
that artisan entertainment who put that
who put that movie out the one nice
thing they ever did for us was was when
the movie hit a hundred million
domestically they sent us each fruit
baskets other than that we were pretty
much just getting yelled at is that it
really yeah so they were scumbags yeah
yeah because there's no way you guys you
guys didn't really get paid a ton for
that movie because nobody knew it was
gonna make get paid its how much did you
make family do you do you get it was it
a few thousand dollars or less and there
was no back-end I need to make the movie
we made about we made exactly five
hundred dollars a week for two weeks so
I made a grand doing the movie I had one
back end point on the movie which I was
so broke when we made it that I begged
the producers to let me sell my back end
point for an extra 500 bucks they were
like we can't do it
well you have 1% back end so I had and I
mean come on you know Hollywood
accounting so it's not
I listed on my Wikipedia page for years
evidently I didn't know this until
somebody told me was was the fact that
we made said we made like 4 million
bucks on the movie which is not true
four million did not make 4 million you
reach the seven figures no didn't reach
into 70 years that's like one of the
biggest horror movies ever look man I I
got a career out of it I did see some
money we had to take him to federal
court in order to get the money
like it's amazing how they make a
$60,000 film turns into 100 million or
250 why and they just can't they gotta
[ __ ] the actors what pieces of [ __ ] was
what was happening at the time was even
funnier because they would be putting
all these articles how variety would be
like artisan entertainment says Blair
which is the most successful film of all
times
and then they'd call us up and they'd be
like guys look I know we made another 80
million in DVD release but between the
press and the PNA and the DVD buybacks
we actually spent like a hundred and ten
here's the thing you guys are actually
in the hole to us so we're gonna have to
knock that off for and so it was it it
was yeah I mean look whatever it might
be with the lowest budget of all time by
the way really so you took they were
like we paid a lot of money for those
fruit pass the distributor yeah yeah I
love the people I made the movie with I
think artisan did a fantastic job
marketing oh yeah and and and and look
bad bad bad feelings about finance aside
I am you know what a cool thing to have
been involved in your place now yeah
it's an iconic [ __ ] movie I just
asked my friend last night I think he's
he's anybody happy yes oh and
general just in general anybody truly
exam is when he goes to Chili's that's
fair when I'm in Encino oh my god but
our people happy am I just surrounded by
miserable people at this moment you are
I've asked myself that I've said that
Tillich is anybody happy or are they
just pretending I don't know I think
people are happy you think people are
happy yeah friend of mine just hung
himself - he's a mental health speaker
okay that wasn't that goes against your
theory yeah yeah I mean it is what it is
like you know people like they do good
and they're not doing good anymore
that's what it is I feel like my wife is
happy
yeah he's delusional when you're here
you said used to be wrong maybe that's
it no I think yeah I think that but as I
was talking to natasha Lyonne and she
was talking about her boyfriend Fred
Armisen
and she was like Fred's happy friends
fritz really happy every morning he
wakes up and eats Grape Nuts and he
loves his Grape Nuts he's just so happy
to get right not to make him happy play
songs and eat grapes I was like that's
so weird
yeah that's not like a fun way to wake
up hot girl in your bed and having Grape
Nuts no not at all a fun way to wake up
yeah I feel like you can have that I
feel like that's an attainable dream for
you you can make it yes yeah yeah the
loving person next to me forget it yeah
I I guess no I don't know other than my
wife I don't know anybody that I would
be like yeah that person is just a happy
person who married a happy / I did marry
a hurry person yeah she is she's an
optimistic pleasant happy person yep
true look I'd love my wife but she's not
happy but she's angry she is she's
Canadian
so angry people if they're angry at home
man oh they're polite but angry but part
of Canada she should screw up in Toronto
okay yeah what does she do she's an
actress she's on Broadway right now in
New York City you say maybe she's angry
that you're in a movie but she's on
Broadway you know she's doing just [ __ ]
yeah she's doing a all be played the
Edward all people
three tall women with Laurie Metcalf and
Linda Jackson yes absolutely he has
eight they open this Thursday that's
amazing
are you staying here for it yeah word
work temper and New Yorkers we've been
here since January with the kid and the
dog and and we're here through the end
of June do you like it here I love it
here yeah where'd you grow up I grew up
in Pennsylvania okay she grew up in
Toronto so were Northeast people or how
did you meet her we met at a pool party
sorry neither of us were swimming if it
makes a difference I love it we met at a
pool party at a mark do plazas house and
we we had a mutual friend and I asked
for her phone number I'd loved her I'd
seen her on stage a few times and always
loved her had a talent crush on her and
I asked I asked our buddy fur for her
phone number and he was like it's kind
of a stoner he was like yeah ask her and
she evidently said yeah give him a
number and then a week later I texted
him back I was like so did she not
meanwhile she was evidently real not
happy with me she was like who is this
douchebag right ask for my number and
I'm never calls me so when you called
her and you just you call her for the
first time as you text I would have to I
mean such such better potential for
answer and less potential for disaster
yeah and an embarrassment cuz you get to
edit a text you can think through your
[ __ ] well though it's a little more
difficult to edit a text because of
three dots come up on the iPhone unless
they're looking for you know and that's
only if you allow that you don't have to
allow them to see the e responding oh
how do we turn that off I didn't even
know you could turn that I know the read
receipts you can turn off I didn't
realize you could turn off the three
dots too sure you turn off anything you
want no guys remember that baby that
just speaking of iPhones the really
great thing you could do and I with an
iPhone is film a great movie like unsane
which is now in theaters and this thing
it's really scary it's really
looks really really good it kind of it's
a cool demented movie it's got it's got
a little bit of a social message but
really it just it's just fun to watch
and Claire Foy yeah Claire Foy who's the
lead who played the Queen in that show
the crown I don't know if you guys saw
that it was great she was fantastic and
that demolishes everything she ever did
with this performance she is fierce and
scary and mean and awesome in this she's
such a fantastic yeah basically the lady
has a stalker or she says she has a
stalker and then she goes to a therapist
cuz she's seen the stalker all the time
and then the I guess based on the
trailer the therapist ends up locking
her up in a mental institution and then
you start to not be able to tell if she
is locked in there against her will or
if she actually is crazy I mean I mean
which is one of my reoccurring
nightmares yeah as if you're in a mental
institution and you're like I'm not
crazy they're like yeah that's what
people say in the mental institution and
because like being in being like I
didn't do it but even worse in prison
than in prison because the crazy people
in the mental and mental institution
probably actually believes that they're
not crazy but aren't we all in a prison
guys what I'm just saying is we're all
in a prison you know but I mean like a
crazy person
uh-huh if they're really crazy would
nothing that they're crazy they'd be
like I'm not supposed to be in here no I
I mean I remember a long time ago this
is back to the 90s the last time I did
acid but got acid trying to go like no I
know you think that this thought is
insane because I'm an acid but there
really is a party in the trunk of my car
I say dude I need you to come see it I
really need you I just need you to tell
me that I'm not burning in a gas
on acid to say I'm good you just tell me
five faces bring and you were sure your
brain wouldn't lie to you I was I was
pretty sure I needed didn't you throw
water on it instead of waking your
roommate up I did that first but it was
still burning
who is that it's that waterproof fire
face if you look in the mirror and it
was on fire no you probably under the
influence of drugs oh yeah
no it's true why did you stop doing acid
it sounds like it's smart enough to say
yes it was quick put in the toilet with
the waters
thank God the nineties here over yeah
well I do wait wait did you stop doing
drugs altogether I did a long time ago
cuz cuz my face always got on fire I
need a beard now there's a lot more to
burn
oh that was Michael Jackson ooh caught
on fire he lit him on fire
was it terrible yeah yeah and then he
died they did none of that no it was
much much later but he did he's asleep
he wasn't acquitted that that might have
been the inciting incident though we as
scalpers I feel like there's there's
some direct line then to pain pills
maybe we could draw there right pain
pills a lot of people after an injury
get hooked on [ __ ] pain pills and
that's the beginning of the end right
and and now I mean with the deoxys and
the [ __ ] fentanyl that's scary man
but yeah I've got a buddy of mine who
who works in recovery in Los Angeles and
everybody they're they're they're lacing
fentanyl with with the dope out there
right now and people are just over this
is a comedy show why am I talking about
because no it's just because I feel like
that was one of the things he was on he
was he was on the Twilight sleep drugs
in the fentanyl what it was was that him
or was that print I'm Tara French was on
I don't know Michael Jackson was did
propofol yeah
trying to sleep Conrad Murray dr. Conrad
Murray Gordon monitor improperly port
Conrad Murray he's still in today all
right good singer than oh he's out he
only did it he did like a couple of
years oh really yeah what should we do
we have to breaker do want to just keep
going well we should we should what's
your scare you hanging I'm fine but you
can also kick me out okay okay that's
fine you want to bring Joe in yeah yeah
I'll just bring Joe list in I'll put him
over there put him where next to you yes
yes Joe do you know Joe list he's a
comedian his Netflix special I love
Julis premiered on that's very good
honey our list hello Joe on Friday this
is Netflix's Joe list also you may have
seen them from The Tonight Show your
credits got a lot better over the last
weekend yes thank you but yes thank you
is exciting it's been a crazy week
unbelievable I didn't see a special I
heard it was great I didn't side The
Tonight Show heard you killed yeah it
was exciting and I get a kind of a
standing O situation which was very nice
to be honest they were standing for
everybody that came out so I know but
doesn't matter yeah but people keep
running you guys standing oh yeah yeah
yeah I did and in Fallon say something
about that like at the end like oh it's
a standing wave crowd the Attic the
cameras went to the standing on what
show actually showed it so it was pretty
exciting so and Jim Jefferies was on and
I could hear him talking while I was
before and like he had a couple
cocktails and then Lahey would say like
that's great that's a great joke so
while you were shooting you could you
could hear yes like I'm in the middle of
my set I can hear I mean he was being
nice but like I could hear like just
like oh that's good like I was doing a
joke about weightlifting and guys the
grunt I'm a hack but some lady I was
going like and some lady went yeah and I
was like shut the [ __ ] up
he [ __ ] snapped to call her country
with directors that I worked with before
weird where I'm in the middle of doing a
scene and and they're back
like yeah yeah that's great here you
I've never heard that while I was acting
or conversely yeah yeah I wouldn't think
that there'd be hecklers or people
trying to include themselves on the show
at the Tonight Show
well I guess people they were heckling
it was like a mother and daughter and
they were heckling the whole show I
wasn't listening because I was in the
back you know masturbating but they were
just heckling the whole time I guess
Jimmy had to be like hey you got to stop
we're gonna kick you out it's like a
whole situation down the commercial
break did he say that I guess yeah Italy
he said it like a lot like in the middle
of an interview second no that would've
been great though okay shut up oh shut
up in the audience who does it who goes
to a TV taping and like tries to be a
part of the show like if anyplace you're
gonna realize that no it's the performer
show maybe that's the night show kela
drinking yeah she did it they got free
tickets probably from out of town had a
couple drinks and I'm with him I also
like to think that maybe it was the
audience giving the standing Oh to drown
out the hecklers it was it was like
everybody rose in solidarity and gave
you a slow clap just to be like we're
with you not with the hecklers that
might be I appreciate that
yeah either way it counts but yeah it
was also it wasn't it wasn't 8:00 p.m.
taping to be there just breathing
hecklers yeah which is a Thursday night
show Friday right yeah second taping so
yeah that's better for a comedy show
yeah it was kind of night felt like a
normal time to be on stage right stead
of 5:00 o'clock they don't tape at like
5:00 5:30 yeah do you actually enjoy it
or or do you just enjoy the fact that
you did it I'm terrified the whole time
leading up but I actually got into a
pretty good place this time I was like I
got it there's gonna be good this will
be fun or whatever he felt good about
the set I feel pretty good about the set
yeah and it was the first time I've done
a late night where I didn't flub a line
I've I've done three before and I've
flubbed a line at some point right just
yeah it's hot as your head just gets out
of in front of your stuff and you're
like this is insane do you go back and
have them take it out or just leave it
in I just left it in all three times I
guess they would if it was a major
problem yeah they only I should say
Conan they
did offer and then they were like it
looks better with it because I was set I
was trying to say I'm traumatized and I
went I'm sure I'm sure I'm trauma I'm
traumatized right now and I get like
kind of a low yeah yeah so they're like
it makes you look better but I think
they just didn't want to edit so like it
yeah it's [ __ ] stressful that's why I
hate all the every YouTube of every
late-night ever there's at least one guy
really seems nervous I'm like built to
this moment it's nerve-wracking this is
camera [ __ ] it's TV people would just
Conte too though you no matter what you
do there's always somebody [ __ ] you
obviously you killed you got a standing
O they can't knock the set so you know
yeah you look you look nervous he didn't
look comfortable yeah it's uh and your
paintings got to be a little slower to
write has to be especially with the
applause breaks like they you'll get
like a delayed one I thought it was one
one in a joke she got got like you were
ready to go on the next one all of a
sudden they started clapping like okay I
got to wait this out yeah it's weird and
then sometimes you'll have an applause
that makes a tag just seem [ __ ]
where like the tagline is like that's
what I said like that's right just left
that but congratulations man and this
night when did this special what's a
special called it's the stand-ups the
season two of the standard so it's a
series more of than a special rule okay
that's not two half hour on nefeli
that's great dude yeah it's exciting
about Tuesday and it's just been it's
been insane it's like it's overwhelming
I feel like [ __ ] George Bailey
everyone's just writing really nice
things and it's who's George Bailey
sweet he's uh it's wonderful life okay I
didn't recognize his name from the film
I'm here to plug it isn't that what
would have happened if he never existed
how would life have been for those
people yeah that's like the last 45
minutes and then he comes back and it's
it's especially you guys should watch it
it's really know I've seen I've seen the
yeah I don't remember it yeah no it is a
good one well anyone comes and says
really nice things and they bring them
money it's the whole thing it's not
every Christmas Eve yeah yeah just black
and white no I'm looking at it right now
it's uh
just watching it 19:46 I'm just looking
at the actual picture okay I see I see
him in his [ __ ] dumb TV family did
you watch the Netflix special back no no
I won't watch that I watched The Tonight
Show is that the seller which was fun
they put it on
are you comfortable watching in front of
people I could never I've done that one
time and I actually did one of the bass
but I can't watch it with people in the
room yeah it was pretty brutal who's at
the cellar and then first of all gnome
the owner plays music on Friday night so
he's playing and they're like we got to
put it on and I was like why gnomes
playing and they're like nah well tell
him to stop soul is the manager walks
over and tells gnome to stop playing his
music at his own Club and I'm like well
this is uncomfortable and you could just
feel the vibe of like I'm gonna go watch
Joel it like everyone is just been
singing along so they put it on but yeah
it was like brutally uncomfortable but
people were laughing and like Ryan
Hamilton was there who's like the
sweetest man you can't find a more
encouraging man than Ryan no no he was
like belly laughing and I think it was
all fake and then I had to go to the
village underground my set was like at
exactly that time I mean Hardy fook-la
was hosting so I was fine but he's like
this guy was just on The Tonight Show
and then I go up and just [ __ ] eat it
for like five minutes
what's like 12:30 and the show started
11:00 and they're drunk and it's Friday
night and they don't give a [ __ ] so is
literally bombing I ended up getting
them when I went into some dick jokes
but I was just eating it 30 seconds
after my triumphant don't you hate a big
intro when you get a big intro like this
guy just and then you go up and you know
the crowd is like this guy [ __ ]
stinks stinks and I think what they're
doing is they're like okay show me right
all right all right big shot yeah see
like like like the the pressure to
perform just goes up by powers of 10 I
actually said that was of expectation I
feel like the only way anybody has ever
liked me in anything is because of low
expectations right they go in with low
expectations like I actually changed the
inside I would give the intro to the
hosts but I'm like I think I'm
sabotaging my I finally stopped doing it
III thought we always had the hosts say
ladies and gentlemen do you like special
guests
you're in for a treat yeah I guess
that's why everybody thought you were
like brilliant in Blair Witch because
they thought you were just a dead guy
who had a camera on him they even know
you were an actor I mean yeah I talked
in that movie so much better than most
of you guys talk right so the
expectations are low make sense
it's a does that is that enough to take
away the high from The Tonight Show like
is that how quickly no I mean I still
felt I mean it's actually helped because
you're bombing and you're like you guys
don't know [ __ ] you so yeah I don't know
I feel good it feels it's exciting you
know yeah it's fun it's fun too cuz most
of the times you're just you know doing
a [ __ ] bar show and new right so it's
nice to have a few moments of like
feeling like you're in show business
there's there's things that like you
feel validate you when you're performing
like all right that makes that
validation I'm not worthless
I actually am good at what I do because
this these people said it and then
people watched it and enjoyed it and you
feel validated well especially when
you're meeting people like regular
people well they're like oh you're
competing over here or something no
you're a comic and you can be like oh
that's a nice shirt like a yeah we'll
assume that you're like a make-a-wish
kid that's like open like because they
don't know who you are no idea yeah I
mean they know you are they don't know
some know who I am a lot don't yes yeah
I go for the Lions too yeah is it ever
the crowds fault she said always wrong
it's never the crowd these commedia I'm
like well what do you mean like I'm
saying the same exact things that I said
before he didn't say that miss
documentary when they were [ __ ]
talking at governors he didn't say it
wasn't their fault right it's funny how
he changes to and then know what they're
just not laughing I stink sometimes I
suck and these are the times where they
saw whatever you but we most guys know
right now see it's a crowd it is yeah
you this time we're through it could be
who's opening for you they said a wrong
tone or whatever it I just came in maybe
the piss cuz the Brooke shows running
late they're not getting drinks it could
be a million different things but I'll
go on sometimes and go I was wrong the
cellar was good one night or whatever or
I didn't have and I wasn't that great I
didn't give you people what you deserve
like this
nights from [ __ ] around I'm not that
good we know it right but that's when
you're just trying stuff what do ya word
you just don't have it there's nice
where you're just off this this actually
go on you just don't click you know
there's plenty times I'm just not yeah
I'm delivering this stuff shitty did you
uh you watch the other Netflix specials
no I have it I mean I saw some of the
tapings but I can't I can't watch it's
brutal yeah I don't like it either why
don't you like to watch it do you get
like impatient or you get depressed I
just hate myself and then also it's like
there's no comedy on TV does not
translate like even like you know bring
the pain is like an amazing special but
if you saw it lie it would be a hundred
times better it's hard to capture so you
like the joke is better than that or I
hate my face and my teeth and a deep
deep hatred for myself yeah I mean it's
it's horrible I hate everything I've
said so far for where we're going other
people like it see people seem to like
it they're writing nice things to me
that's great yeah it's nice and then the
people that don't I've been writing back
which is actually kind of enjoyable
everyone's like just ignore it block
them but I'm like I've kind of been
getting in dialogues with people it's
kind of fun yeah sometimes they
sometimes they're dicks and then you're
a dick back and they'll go I was just
kidding and what did I saying about what
are they saying well one guy I had three
different people I do a joke about a
woman tell me I have a five head and
then hijinks ensues I've had like you're
a hack that's from like middle school
I'm like yeah I'm not presenting it as I
came up with five head I'm telling the
story about girls in middle school
saying it right and then there's jokes
that fall like jokes are about Hugh
being called that not the fact that it's
funny that a bigger forehead would be a
five yeah it's like my bits not like hey
folks I just came up with a funny thing
to call people with big foreheads how
about this five heads right and then you
follow up with a good Deez Nuts joke so
it's like I'm just I brought to a guy I
was like well you just you don't
comprehend the joke he's like you suck
this is hack you should be embarrassed
and I was like well I don't mind you
don't like me but like that I'm just
doing a joke about a middle school girls
saying this to me and then he wrote back
the rest was great
sometimes if you write back there
especially when they know that wrong one
soon they won't admit it but it's like
when you presented like that's all right
yeah I misread his joke
yeah what's so often it's just a cry for
attention too sure whether it's negative
or positive and when you stand up in
general you're right I also always think
jock is funnier once you explain why
it's funny
oh you like that let me tell you why you
didn't laugh let me tell you why this
joke is empirically funny I'll explain
it to you I enjoy that I'll do political
stuff that I'll explain my own poignancy
yeah Jim does like pop-up video but for
comedy where he just explains all of his
jokes right after them I would love to
do that go over my old specials and just
destroy them in a pop-up video style
well that's right
I mean Florentine in destroy his stuff
but you did a whole album just reading
your old joke books right yeah my first
comedy notebook yeah yeah in the jokes
are some of them good its know what's
great not one what's great about the
album is he doesn't comment on any of it
he just reads the jokes except like
every like 20 minutes you're just
hearing I can't hold it in my first
comedy notebook has a maybe my second
coming up it has a cutout from the
newspaper of Dane Cook taped into it and
then a rabbit Kelly sticker why those
were my guys when I was tourgasm and
stuff yeah yeah well it was like pretty
tourgasm but I would see them at like
the comedy connection where are you from
Boston yeah is there anybody room by
within the always just talk about the
old connection that [ __ ] it was like
a black box oh I loved it with that what
an amazing place that I was great 500
seats I had sex on that stage one time I
also slept on that stage that was like
my home night two different nights the
night I had sex on it I got the hell out
because they've someone realized we were
over there and turned the spotlights on
and we kind of scrammed it was classic
why did you sleep there I was just drawn
I was so drunk and then I had driven
into the city I live in my parents house
I will drive home so I just curled up on
the stage I thought it'd be like and
there was a green room with like a couch
but I thought I'd be like romantic like
I slept on the stage
meanwhile is like a couch with like
blankets I was like no no I'm this I'm
on the stage what's the guy from yes
that doesn't delete say like John and it
was his name John Hanson yeah he sleeps
on the stage a lot of times the night
before I've heard that's weird
I like how artistic you are about it
yeah sleep on the stage to get closer to
the art you'll collage about it memories
uh whatever you need to do and I'll a
little bang on there I feel like two
pictures is not a collage sure it is
like that's cheating that's a really
lazy ass I mean it's not the greatest
collage in the world but if you've gone
through and cut a picture out you know
how long it takes the kind of picture of
Bob Kelly out now Kelly in unsafe I
watched him on the big screen it was so
exciting I didn't know he was in there
is he in on safe he's the cop he's the
same insane I'm sorry sorry golf way
cold way was saying he knows him was
friends with him yeah yeah yeah I didn't
know he was great I didn't have any
themes with him but I watched him in the
movie and thought he was awesome he was
uh it was fun it was really fun so
you're okay watching your own movies no
I you don't like it no it's excruciating
your self in your face too
I get most of the time my friend of mine
asked me he was like how's the movie I
was like I'm fat that's my review it's
my to word review I thought you were
great I thought it was great
oh thanks fun it's fun to see a friend
on screen though you're not expecting
them yes you're like what or can't I
wrote it for you what they can totally
yeah well if he was like the bad guy I
feel like if you guys switched roles it
would be unsettling to see Bobby you
know you know if you if you like
watching [ __ ] Game of Thrones and
Ryan Hamilton was great yeah I mean it
look especially the role I play in this
movie is not I felt I mean I felt so bad
for my wife we went to a screening and
we got in the cab to drive back out and
say I'm so sorry I'm so I'm so sorry you
have to sleep next to me - yeah yeah
it is funny though that we just see the
one thing about ourselves that we hate
the most and that's all we'll see for
the entire thing like you saw a fat guy
on the screen for the whole movie
usually to your face but you just can't
you can't but yet you can't get over it
right you can't as no really we're
really vain [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's what it is nothing wrong with
that
well I thought so I've seen the one flaw
no and just and just locking on to it
for the entire thing there's something
wrong with that little walking on part
might not be good not great noticing
it's okay of course noticing it is fine
but when that's all you see that's and
it's bad that's it did speaking of
speaking of my 11 o'clock yoga class it
did I watch the movie I was like I I got
a workout yeah that's a compliment about
you now but also means that you he also
saw effect and he's saying whoo right
you were the like [ __ ] in fairness I was
I was in I had tried really hard I just
gotten done with a directed movie and
I'd been in post-production for about
six months
just eating in a dark room and I
finished that and I started getting back
in shape and I was like I should you
know I got I gotta get a gig I got a
Gabey gig and I got a I got called and
asked to do this thing and the first
time I got on the phone with Stephen
he was like yeah now you got to put 20
pounds back on oh that's nice yeah I'd
worked really hard
why do you want you to put 20 back on um
because because I play a creepy pathetic
stalker okay who essentially lives in
his dad's basement today I had a pitch I
was like it's like what did this guy's
like a creepy outward-bound counts and
he was like nah he's just on the
internet and eating takeout food so yeah
I just saw him is misunderstood
that's a joke it's called unsane
well I go say it I don't think about
that by the way anybody who defends my
character you should not let them date
your sister all right I'm gonna try to
see this movie I'm trying to see it it's
it's work so how did you gain the weight
did you you because some of these actors
just stopped losing weight really I mean
my default my default is I go up right
so what I'm working countered to my
default you know I just would I just
state like I like a normal human being
does and didn't work out how long did it
take you to put 20 on like three hours
how long did you have before you had to
put it on before you couple tunes come
on I didn't know he was very he's
actually very respectful he calls you
and I didn't have to audition he said do
you want to do this gig I said yes he
said you have months to prepare for it I
was like that's because that it helps it
helps and yeah I'm not a guy because I'm
not you know a movie star I don't get
jobs that far in advance they're usually
like great we need you in San Juan you
know Tuesday Tuesday okay okay I'd
better figure out you know how cops are
so this is one that I actually I I got
to do the very creepy fun research which
is discovered that there is a whole
sub-genre of stalker thrillers of misery
play misty for me King of Comedy
it's for the white female like the list
kind of goes I'm windy cuz I die I put
it out there on Twitter I was like what
it what are the good stalker movies I
was like [ __ ] there's actually a lot of
her movie Clint Eastwood is a radio guy
and play misty for me amazing that's a
great movie Oh amazing
Sondra Locke was the stalker right yeah
where she was at yeah yeah I think so
wasn't she think so I don't know I
didn't see that one either yeah this is
real life she was in like [ __ ] any
which way he can and every which way but
loose and [ __ ] a sudden impact sudden
impact yeah it's already here until he
dumped it and she wasn't his movies
anymore
yep that was animated for a long time
that's that yeah they were a long time
couple then I guess she stopped [ __ ]
Clint she was sexy though she's 70
[ __ ] three well Clint's not a young
man holy [ __ ] I didn't know she was that
old how old is Clint he's in that age
range but I literally had no idea she
was cleansing of Wayne is a that he's
dead yeah he might be ninety almost 85
87
yeah he's 87 he didn't didn't he just
direct a movie last year yeah I think so
yeah Oh what did he direct yeah just try
thinking that too it was something that
oh he just directed that train movie
with the non-actors the actual people oh
that's right the the France train the
terrorists train there was some moves on
and the Marines played themselves yes it
looked like a real pile of [ __ ] not good
merde
you know you're not good